the warmer weather may be to blame for
those bugs coming out of hiding 8 News
now's Mary Jane beliesza is live now
with what could be bugging you Mary Jane
you wrote that so I had to keep that on
there how's it looking out there
well Ted you know Springtime is the
start of bug season and experts say now
is the time to protect yourself and your
home and a good tip is keeping shrubs
and trees like this trimmed and the
limbs away from Windows and Doors
spring means plenty of sunshine and
blooming flowers and as more people
spend time Outdoors it's important to
know what to look out for Louisa
messenger specializes in infectious
diseases transmitted by insects at UNLV
she says ticks will tend to hide out on
tall grass and can latch onto your skin
so check your clothing and your dog's
fur before heading inside my bust boots
long trousers especially if you are out
in those kinds of environments
particularly if you're doing outdoor
recreation hiking camping but you may
also just be taking your dog for a walk
while there are only a few cases of West
Nile each year it's still important to
wear long sleeves and have repellent
mosquitoes that transmit West Nile are
the pipe that will bite you early in the
evening just at the dusk so it's a sort
of perfect time that you'll be sat
outside maybe having your dinner during
the summer month mosquitoes like to
breed and still standing water so double
check your watering cans fountains and
pools because it does get so severely
hot here you may also see some insects
coming inside to take shelter Kevin Ras
from JS Pest Control is anticipating a
busy season the length of the wet season
the winter was extremely long so with
the wetter the the season the more bugs
have a chance to to cultivate and become
many he says your best bet is to seal up
your home and cover tiny cracks or holes
this also means carefully inspecting the
inside of your home what's predominant
here in in Las Vegas is a black widow
spider and they have a really nasty
neurotoxin which makes you really really
sick spiders like to climb into shoes
always tap your shoe make sure nobody
comes you know there's nobody in there
now if you don't like using pesticides
there are natural remedies you can use
to deter bugs I like using Irish Spring
soap you just take the bar soap and you
kind of just put it around your door
frame and it also smells really good
reporting live Mary Jane beliesza 8 News
Now